greetings from podcastville you filthy
[__]
uncle joey's joint is brought to you by
blue chew listen there's a new year
coming
and you want to start the year off
[__] stronger than death
slinging dick and hanging out [__]
condoms you understand me
how with bluetooth listen there comes
the point in a man's life where
the machine's not working like the
machine used to
and there's no shame with that your
testosterone levels go
down other factors in your life go down
but what are you going to be walking
around with a gun with three bullets
women are going to talk about you
they're going to say you're a half a
mook
who needs that [__] when you have blue
chew
it's the first chewable dick bill the
same
fda approved active ingredients as
viagra and cialis listen this ain't the
[__] that you get from gus
at the liquor store that tells you you
get it and then you drink and your head
turns red
[__] that this is the real deal it's
prescribed online
by licensed physicians so you don't have
to even go to the doctor's office
or wait online at a pharmacy so right
now
they got a special for the for the joint
listeners
listen you got to end the year all
[__] strong with a
bang you won't get this by [__] you
know thursday
but you'll get this by next week and
you'll be slinging dick and
if your dick is working 100 it could
always be working at 150 percent
you want the [__] woman to leave the
house limping if she ain't limping
you didn't do your [__] job all right
that's where blue chew comes in
visit blue chew blue blue
chew.com and get your first shipment
free
when you press code joey you're just
gonna pay five dollars for shipping
that's it again that's blue like the
color of your nut sack
when you show up at a house filled with
love juice
and canola juice whatever the [__] is in
there that [__] dick vayne will be
popping
when you hit that blue chew dog so
bluechew.com
use code joey and i want to thank
bluechu
for continuing to sponsor the joint
uncle joey's joint
the joint also wants to talk to you
about the best
on it listen you're starting a new year
you want to start off at the right foot
you've been a little goose lately you
know the pandemic
the president your [__]
your grandmother's dying you know
it's too much to even focus into
that's why i'm here with alpha brain i
just finished
a cycle and i'm gonna restart the cycle
again
on the fifth before my knee surgery so
i'm fresh i'm ready to go
i do these for about six weeks and get
tip top and go you guys have seen the
difference
listen to podcast one and listen to this
podcast
everything has improved i mean the
podcast still sucks but
we're trying to do our best in every
single [__] way
but alpha brain is the way to go if you
don't like pills
they come in a powder i love the ruby
grapefruit
you got the nice little lemonade there
instant you just pour it into water and
stir it we still got alpha brain and
pills
which is the flagship we still have
shroom tech
shroom tech immune shroom tech sports
the melatonin spray to help you at night
to relax
the new mood on it is the way to go go
to honor.com right now
and press in church and get 10 off your
order
delivered right to your [__] crib
that's on it
press in church and that's 10 off
delivered
to your [__] crib happy new year
[__] let's get this party started
[Music]
bam
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday
i don't know what it is the 30th who
gives a [__]
all we know is it's the end of the
[__] year that's it
we did it we started off with the church
and now we're here with uncle joey's
joint
and we got from point a to point b i
don't even know how the [__] this
happened
you know i would love to do a year and
recap for you and recap the highlights
of the year
there were no [__] highlights in this
[__] year you know i i
i had a great time you know uh i had my
moments
but uh this was a [__] up year and i
gotta tell you something
you know the only conclusion i could
come up with and this
is just a fat [__] old man that's a
felon
but i'm catholic and
i have religious beliefs you know i have
different beliefs whether it be in
levels of buddhism or whatever the [__]
i believe that the earth you know went
off his axis
on january 26 or 25th or whatever
whatever the day kobe died it's been
feeling
shitty since that day i'll never forget
driving home with steve simone and
something just wasn't right the air
wasn't right
the way the the leaves were blowing and
we landed
as his plane was his helicopter was
[__]
uh crashing so when we got home i saw
the news
in the [__] uh on the internet and i
was like [__]
but you know it's been nonsense downhill
from that right after that
we found out about the pandemic we
closed down
we opened up we moved as a family we
were forced to move
as a family you know now we're closed up
again well not really with the 25
percent
i took my wife out to a restaurant the
other night there was nobody [__]
there but
uh you know la is locked up i hear that
the
the [__] numbers is spreading like
gonorrhea
in l.a one out of [__] 20 people so
my heart goes out to you guys out there
you know i think it's just time to stand
and play it safe
you know i don't know what plans you
have for new year's i was just telling
mike i was online
looking at kisses doing a buy a show
from
udubai whatever the [__] dubai whatever
they want 39.99 up to a thousand dollars
for a [__] ticket
for pay-per-view hey man you got a
couple of your friends together
do a little covert test on them whatever
the [__] you want to do and
smoke some dope and invite them over
because nobody's going to get to do [__]
on new year's eve and i'll tell you even
the numbers in jersey are down
so maybe cutting the bars to 10 o'clock
was a good idea or whatever i don't know
i'm not a scientist when we're gonna sit
here follow the [__] science
all i can do is mind my business not
breathe on your [__] neck
and do the best i can wash my hands
before and after you touch your dick
you know got to wash your hands before
you touch your dick
next thing you know your wife is smoking
your pole she shows up coughing with
congested lungs
because you wanted your dick sucked have
some [__]
have some class have some dignity
anyway yesterday
[Laughter]
yesterday i was at the park with my uh
daughter uh monday i was at the park
with my daughter
[__] beautiful day here in jersey 55
degrees 57 degrees
kids were playing you know my wife was
in physical therapy she uh
heard her planches catastrophes
when we got here playing badminton with
my daughter so she had to wear a cast
for a few weeks
so she's still in physical therapy you
know
they're trying to get us stronger and
stuff she joined the gym to start going
now
but uh i was just sitting at the park
with my daughter we walked around
we i helped to get on some of the stuff
she saw some of the kids from the school
you know whatever they're playing
it's [__] beautiful out you know i go
to take a piss the door is locked
now i gotta hide behind the tree i'm
getting anxiety because if you're
pissing apart
and they catch you they they they label
you a sex offender
because you're in a [__] park now i
gotta register as a sex offender
because i'm 58 and i got to pee every
hour on the [__] hour
so i'm up there by the park and you know
towards the end the sun's starting to go
down not it wasn't going starting to go
down it's like 334
you know it's on the edge it's strong
and she was on the swing
a little girlfriend had left and i went
over and sat on the swing next to her
and it had been the first time we had
sat next to each other on a swing
since i la you know it was a great
little moment i even reminded her of it
and uh we giggled and we just
talked about our year you know i told
her you know
that she was she did great she was a big
girl
you know she handled it great i
asked her what she liked and what she
didn't like i talked to my daughter a
lot i try to
communicate with her a lot you know and
what she liked
what she didn't like so far you know she
gave me kid answers but she also gave me
some pretty intelligent answers and i
was pretty pretty uh
impressed with her she was she was
saying that the schools in l.a don't
have
hallways what the hell is wrong with
that they have no always
they didn't have a gym and didn't have a
cafeteria
at school and that was supposed to be
one of the best schools in l.a that's
how
[__] brainwashed you get out there
sometimes
that that school didn't have a gym a
cafeteria
or hallways they just walked out into
the [__]
you know into the [__] street
whatever so
you know we were talking about [__] like
that
and uh from there we went to carvel
we went to a real carvel and picked up a
little tiny tiny cake from my wife
because that's a tradition
and this year like in in la we have to
buy it at ralph's
and they won't even think of putting
your [__] happy birthday on anything
and if they do they spell it wrong it's
some mexican chick that says
spell's birthday with a v so [__]
uh you know it's a [__] nightmare
so me and mercy when i go what do you
want to do we went over the carvel
and uh i go what do you want to do you
want to [__] cause they caught them
they got sundays you could take like six
to go or
whatever so we just bought a tiny tiny
cake
and a couple friends came over at 5 30
and she was tickled to death she did not
expect to get a cake
and then her and i went to a store we
bought her a card
and on the way out my daughter's like i
think mommy would like this bracelet
it was just some cute little kid
bracelet
like 13 bucks it's like let's get it for
mom if it makes you happy you know and
uh
we came home and when mom got back
we all had a thing for her at 5 30 and
we [__]
took a you know i think she had tears in
her eyes it was great it was just great
to make somebody's [__] day you know
listen man
one thing about me is i'm not
a lot of people always go oh your mother
died
you had to raise yourself you know
people don't know about what you went
through
no a lot of people don't know what i
went through but a lot of people don't
don't also know how much help i really
got
i don't want you guys to think i'm a
[__] i walk on water i got a lot of
help
from a lot of good people a lot of help
i could sit here for [__] hours and
tell you
how much help i got from a great people
yeah this is way before the comedy and
whatever
and that woman upstairs was one of them
that woman upstairs saved my [__]
life he gave me a chance that
i thought nobody would ever give me
again you know she gave me a chance that
be honestly i didn't want i didn't want
the chance of being in a [__]
relationship
i didn't want the chance of having a
girlfriend or responsibility
[__] being married and having a [__]
kid [__]
all that [__] i just wanted somebody i
could sleep with
maybe go to a restaurant with once in a
while and maybe go to a movie with no
[__] commitment
and boy was i [__] wrong
she took me from [__] a to z
and today i look at you guys and tell
you i'm happy
you know she took care of me ralphie may
took care of me josh wolfe took care of
me
joe rogan took care of me ari took care
of me you know
duncan took care of me you guys have no
[__] idea what it takes when you're a
comic and you're
when you're an artist in any any art
form
art understands one of the things that
you have to do as an artist
is help people is help other artists
maybe open up a door for them
you know mike showed up with a light
ideas
that's what we do as artists we we give
each other ideas
to be better we make each other better
why have a friend if they make you
the worst person that you could be you
ever think about that
sometimes we hang out with people like
especially for a guy like me i did coke
for 37 years
i had a ton of friends that didn't do
nothing for you but
bring you you know
bad situations you liked them at the
time
you know what i'm saying i mean hey you
showed up with an ounce of coke ain't
that bad of a [__] guy
but you know when it comes to artistry
and all this type of [__]
i don't even consider myself that i'm
just saying that there was a lot of
[__] help involved
and one of those people that helped me
was my [__] life man
she [__] helped me and in ways that
you know i mean one of the strongest
things she said to me that really
let me know that she was paying
attention
and that she really cared about me and
loved me compared to any other woman i
had been with
with something that blew my mind one
night
she told me when i was high i was high
and i was just getting in
and she didn't know i was high
she told me not high on reefer either uh
she told me that she could tell that was
somebody that didn't have a mother's
love
and that [__] destroyed my insides
boy
finally somebody had figured me the [__]
out
remember how we talk about calling you
out and [__] there's a big difference
between getting called out
and getting figured out somebody [__]
figured
me the [__] out i was blown away that
night i went to [__] sleep and i was
like holy [__]
what the [__] did she just do
she just exposed me
those words from her [__] killed me
that i was i
had the attitude of somebody who was
raised
without a mother that is
[__] horrific that
is [__] horrific and again
if it wasn't for my maturity at the time
or whatever
i would have probably lost called her a
[__] and stormed out here
and this video would probably never be
happening right now
thank god i didn't storm out there like
the [__] that i am
i got insulted you know for all you
people getting salt that easy
i can't believe you say that sometimes
stay warm off the argument throw some
cold water on it
and think about the words that those
people are saying to you
i'm not talking about some jerk off at a
bar who wants to throw
a left hand and [__] remark at you
i'm talking about somebody who loves you
and who's close to you
and for some reason wants to say
something to you to make you better
don't [__] steam off and call them an
[__]
and tell them [__] you you know and
listen i've been guilty of it but
i also know where those people are
coming from there's a lot of people out
there that want to give you advice just
to make you [__] feel bad but there's
a lot of people invite
that are out there to give you advice to
build you the [__] up
those are the ones you want in your life
the ones that give you advice to build
you the [__] up
not the ones that give you advice to
[__] knock you the [__] down [__]
those [__]
i don't need them around me it's so
weird how
you know patreon has been great because
it kept me together it took my you know
anxiety away
it calmed me down in a lot of ways it
took my mind off
what was going on around me when i was
moving in the pandemic
but it also showed me something it
showed me that
there's a lot of people that were stuck
like i was and i'm having an opportunity
to help them and i'm not talking about
another financial way
for some reason or another and it didn't
happen on facebook
and that maybe once or twice on facebook
and it happened maybe once or twice on
twitter but
here's something here's the weirdest
thing
when somebody tape sends me a tape of
that comedy
it breaks my [__] heart for you to
say to me joey
can you look at my comedy and tell me
what you [__] think
don't do that to me you put me in a spot
why don't you just tell me to suck your
dick
you would make it easy at least i know
where i stand
i i don't know where the [__] i stand
when i [__]
you know when you tell me that you want
me to look at you
stand up it just isn't fair to me
i would feel as if
no matter what i said t i was putting
you down that's why i could never do
like
i had a hard time with kill tony i like
the concept of it
but i don't want to chop somebody down i
want to build them up
you know in a funny way and listen some
people say some bad jokes
and we all goof around lord knows i've
said bad jokes
and people have said stuff to me and i
haven't taken it personally
but these are dreams and sometimes
people go a little too far when they
[__] with your dreams
me i'd rather not go there so i don't go
there
but i tell you what i do like like mike
does it a lot
a lot of people do this they just send
me music
they sent music and you know listen
uh if you do a [__] town hall
on pedophilia you know have you seen
that town hall that's going around on
some lady
pedophilia will be accepted by the year
anyway i can't do my work
around that i would love to tell you
guys that i could listen to a podcast
and do work
i cannot do it cannot even [__] come
close to it
but i'll tell you what i can do i can
listen to music
and do work so for some reason or
another
you know it comes in patches it comes in
patches
you know for two weeks everybody will
hit you up with emails they want an
autograph
go [__] yourself whatever joe dimaggio
i'm gonna go back and forth and packages
and send [__]
just wait till you see me at a [__]
comedy show
a [__] autograph whatever we tend and
then
then they go away then the autograph
people go away then
it's like you get another batch of weird
people
asking for weird requests you know this
wasn't weird this was just people going
hey man
i'm gonna send you some music that i
play or in a band i'm in
and i gotta tell you something i think
six people
have sent me music and i liked
all six of them a girl mary
sent me some uh a couple tracks
and she sang i want to be around holy
[__]
it was [__] good another guy try
lucky or whatever had some
blood bluesy stuff for me or whatever
[__] great i mean
you know i love all this [__] it's not
like i'm listening i don't want you to
think i'm i'm the masked
[__] whatever i'm i'm not a judge off
the mass magician panel
i don't want you to think i can get your
job with snoop dogg i don't know anybody
so if you're sending me music because
you think
that i can make a call to interscope
records or some
guys i don't know anybody in the music
business
i'll tell you how bad i am at the music
business i can't even get you a booking
at the troubadour i mean nobody can
right now
but who do i you know i don't know
anybody
but as far as what i'm saying is
i'm seeing you let me tell you what i'm
saying
i'm seeing the same
[__] where i was in 91
i'm seeing people who have talent
all right look this is [__] crazy
they have
talent they just don't know
what the next move is there is
nothing worse in the world
than knowing that you have talent
but not knowing what the next [__]
move is
it is horrible you know you watch tv
you see a guy playing an hobo you're
like i want to do that
you know what i'm saying like you're
like that flowing
the guy says he like i want to play the
oboe you don't even know what the
[__] hobo is
but you want to play the oboe or
whatever you know
there's nothing and then you go and you
you listen to music you know you go on
youtube
how to play the oboe whatever the [__]
you know
great oboe soloists of the past whatever
the [__]
you know you know i don't [__] know
you learn and then you [__]
you go to a pawn shop because where else
can you find an old boat
an old boat who plays an oboe you ever
talk to anybody who plays an hobo
have you ever met anybody who plays
snowball i figured they all killed
themselves by this point
you played your boat for a few years you
walk into a pawn shop you drop it off
and you go
i'm done with the elbow and you walk
right to the nearest bridge
you don't even leave a note you're so
[__] brokenhearted
the old bow left you down but
you're at a point you're at a point in
your career where
you don't know what the [__] you want to
do
and guys for you guys who have gone
through it
how [__] frustrating is it and it's
anything it's
law it's plumbing and how i always love
using plumbing i love plumbing i just
didn't like the shitty smell but i love
plumbing i could
i could have been a great plumber if it
wasn't for the smell and the oldest
everything around it you gotta touch
toilets if it was new construction i'm
in
i could pick up a toilet like but if
it's a toilet that's used he'd listen
i wouldn't touch that [__] with
a hazmat suit on
those toilets all have covered from the
piss around it to the piss on the side
to the pistol and other there's like 19
levels of degrees of piss
on a [__] toilet but like i was
saying
that all these people have talent
they just don't know where the [__] to
start but again
it's not 1969 where well
mike you know i like your band your
guitar play is good
i like the drummer i think we could go
into the studio
now you could just get two iphones
four mics figure it out the [__]
table
and start sending stuff out to [__]
uh you know the music
industry has changed so much just like
so the comedy business
that it's hands-on you don't need
[__] uh what's his name who's the guy
that produced
mutt lang you don't need my lane no more
you are your own [__] lang
think about it
think about it that's it the mutland
days are long [__] gone
you could create your own videos at home
beats
you know you could shoot videos i know a
friend of mine
in north jersey unknown band not
signed by anybody they put albums out
music's okay you know it's not my genre
of music
they shoot videos that you know just
because
you're not with [__] you know our
iris to records
rca records whoever the [__] is left
doesn't mean you don't have a [__]
band doesn't mean you don't have a
[__] band
this is your year 2021 is about a lot of
[__] things that's coming up 2021 is
a very [__] important year in your
life
it's gonna be a really important year
more ways than one
this is a comedy podcast but i also try
to make it a reality [__] podcast
not a reality like you know you're gonna
meet your next husband on this show
there ain't no husband's here meet a
millionaire or whatever
the reality is i try to tell you how the
[__] it is in a comical way without us
losing our [__] minds
you know it's going to be a rough
[__] year
i i hope you guys don't think that at
midnight
covers just gonna [__] click its
heels like the wizard of oz and
go back to kansas wherever the [__] it
came from
no we're gonna go in a little deeper uh
is gonna be a [__] uh you know
hopefully the vaccines and i hate
talking about this [__]
i'm just planning out the year for you
[__]
so you've got two or three months of
journaling
and planning out where it goes from here
because
once this [__] rocket ship is ready
to take off again
you're gonna be off and running you've
been on hold for two [__] years
you don't have to if you're going to
sleep you better do it now
if you're going to rest you better do it
now if you want to watch that series
you've always wanted to watch on netflix
you might as well do it now breaking bad
the sopranos
star trek do it now
because in five or six months if you got
any heartbeat to you if you're a man if
you're a woman
if you've got any such balls to you
you're sick and tired of sitting around
more businesses are going to be opened
more
opportunities are going to be out there
so yeah you might be a little bit
[__] down right now today i'm sure
you
are i'm a little down too you know i
didn't make a lot of money last year
either i'm [__] you know
i didn't have the road either i missed
the road too i'm heartbroken but
[__] it you gotta suck it up [__]
suck it up and no better days are coming
i don't give a [__] if you take the
vaccine or not it's got nothing to do
with me
i don't have i just want you to be happy
and healthy
that's it i don't give a [__] if you
want to take the vaccine
i don't give a [__] it's got nothing to
do with me it's not my business
none of my politics i don't care who you
voted for if you didn't vote
i don't give a [__] about that all i
want you to do is to be [__] happy
but the part to be happy is i'm telling
you right now as friends
whatever you got left to do painting
that wall
you know taking naps you better do it
now because once this comes back
we're going what's that no uh no sleep
to brooklyn
remember beastie boys no sleep
to brooklyn no sleep till you're dying
now
we're going for it you've been at home
[__] sitting on your ass for two
[__] years it's gonna be
18 months by the time this gets going so
i don't know what your [__]
expectations are
so you better start speed reading you
better start
preparing you know you're gonna have to
do three years and two
whatever the [__] you need to do you
better start doing it now get all this
stuff this [__] out of your way
if you're addicted to something get it
out of the way now
don't wait to the first i gotta admire
john mulaney for what he did my heart
goes out to him
all you guys know i'm a big fan of john
[__] melanie's
and i love the guy but listen during
this pandemic
[__] uh we knocked uh the skeletons
came knocking on the door
we had too much free time too much
mental capacity everything was up in the
air
we thought about things i mean i i got
accused of something
uh from a girl that happened 22 [__]
years ago
i we were doing blow we went back to her
house
and i asked her a question i touched her
thigh she said no
she drove me home and eight weeks ago
she remembers and wants to call me up
and say
i didn't like what you did that night
well what the [__]
i've done 20 shows with you since that
night and now
you remember i'm not mad i'm not mad
enough
at all for saying this this is just what
happened
when you have all this free time on your
hand
all this bad [__] all these bad memories
because you think every everything
surrounds you everything around you is
mad
everything that's drawing out of you you
sit down to watch the news
it's bad you talk to your neighbor i got
laid off
covered you talk to your cousin i can't
get unemployment on the phone
i keep pressing too they don't even want
to talk to spanish people
you know you talk to this guy he broke
his leg playing basketball i mean
bad luck is around you so it's drawing
it out of you don't let it draw
the [__] out you don't let it draw the
negative
out of here at all at all just [__]
keep it together
because everything around you is so
[__] negative
everything around you you know ever
since i stopped watching the news look
at me
i'm a way better person i got blood
under my lids again
if the watching the news drops the
[__] blood takes it out of your
[__] eyelids
that's how much energy it was taken from
you i had a [__] stop
so don't get taken away i know we had a
bad year this year since march
but 2021 is gonna be such a [__]
great year it's gonna start off slow
i don't want you to think you're gonna
wake up friday morning and it's gonna be
you know gone with the wind
you want a blonde they're gonna be out
there like grease dancing
no it's not it's gonna start off a
little slow
you might get a little bit more
depressed but don't let yourself get
depressed
january and february i'll be a little
slow i don't know what's going to be
happening out in la
with the shutdown or what type of
shutdowns you got but isn't it weird
that florida is wide open
la is closed and they have more cases
than florida makes you [__] think
about a lot of [__] [__] doesn't it
you know i don't know what's going to
happen in january and february like i
said
that's why i chose to do the surgery
january 8th
so i don't have anything on my you know
what if it's
if you know anything about my
neighborhood it's going to be [__]
cold as [__] in this neighborhood so
there's nowhere for me to go i'm gonna
chill write some jokes
i promise you i promise you i will start
i've been i ain't even gonna say
i've been trying to [__] outline the
new book
because i had to shorten it yet again
because i found a [__] that shouldn't
even be in there i could
i just want to write the one book once
you write one it's like killing somebody
once you kill one person the rest of
them are easy you just gotta kill the
first one first
get over that one then the second one's
a little hard the third one you're off
and [__] running you know i'm saying
so that's all i wanted to check in with
you it was a bad year
we had a great time they couldn't stop
me
i kept doing a podcast under whatever
conditions
i wrapped up the mummy's head to leave
towards the end we had to wrap up his
head when he was coughing
the whole table would rattle and [__]
the poor bastard
but he's up there in boston doing great
he's got his patreon
going you know he's trying to make it
happen and i'm happy for him leaning
to get out of that way also we needed to
just
move on with his life and uh you know
get it going i mean we weren't gonna do
i miss him i miss lee with all my
[__] heart i call him twice a day
i torment him i tell him to open up his
window
feed the flies you know i taught open up
a new restaurant chain called lizard
meat
i got tons of ideas for him he's not
taking edibles lately
i think he only took edibles the other
night and he twitched uh
he's just trying to take it easy and i
tell him he wants to do all these things
and i'm like what are you going to do
where you going to go i go stay up there
stay with mom for a few weeks put a
little office together in the basement
get a little
business going get your patreon going
lose 60 pounds get healthy
and hopefully leo get healthy and he'll
get back to normal and everything will
be
i mean he is normal what the [__] am i
saying he's great he's great he still
has a great sense of humor
we laugh we [__] kid you know i was
liking to do a zoom with them but
these [__] zooms start to suck i
don't want to [__] get
zoomed up i got a list of zooms next
week i'm doing
i think i'm doing that one with duncan
before i [__]
go into surgery to talk about the state
of the [__] earth the world whatever
and that's pretty much it guys i just
wanted to get on here with you guys
and tell you listen man it's been a
[__] hell of a year
and i'm happy and proud
that you let me come into your [__]
house
into your home into your heart once a
[__] week
for two hours a week i want to also
thank you
for having my back when these lunatics
tried to go after me
for saying that somebody sucked my dick
23 years ago who gives a [__]
nobody gives a [__] about that person
but all of a sudden they gave a [__]
for that one [__] hour nobody gives a
[__] it's all [__] but i'm happy
that you had my back i'm happy that you
had my back
on stage this year whether you came to
see me in vegas
at the comedy store in atlanta
we only had like three gigs together
this year we had atlanta
vegas and tempe on valentine's day
that's the only gigs i got everything
else was at the comedy store
i want to thank you for supporting me
there i want to thank you for supporting
me on the [__]
ozzy's boneyard you know you guys have
just been uh
uh just [__] hope man
i didn't know what was gonna happen when
this podcast
switched i had no idea what was gonna
happen when i moved i had no idea what i
was gonna do with my life
i mean right now i still love doing
stand-up comedy but
i'm not falling all over myself to get
out there
i'm not going to get on a [__] plane
and do it none of that shit's happening
whatsoever
i'll do it at uncle vinnie's i got next
tuesday and wednesday
and then i got the surgery on the 8th
and then it's going to be around two or
three weeks
before i could get back on but once i
get back on
it's going to be straight on to a
[__] april i don't know
the situation with the soprano movie
with the many saints in newark i don't
know what's going on
with it if it's coming on hbo maxim
uh march or if it's coming out in
october
i don't know i don't know nothing the
only thing i do know is
with some bad [__] we went from
the church to the joint without missing
a [__] beat
and you guys were here with me we had a
couple difficulties a couple of weeks
who doesn't when you you know you're
gonna break a few eggs when you make it
you gotta break a few
uh shells when you make an egg right
shit's gonna happen everything is not
gonna be perfect i never said i was
perfect
one thing i did say is that you could do
whatever the [__] you want with your
life
and next year is your [__] life
next year is your world i don't give a
[__] when anybody tells you yeah
we're gonna start off slow but once this
gets going
every desire every dream you've ever had
you're gonna [__] execute because
that's it this can't happen to us
ever again this can never happen to us
again what happened
the last nine months and what's gonna
happen listen
i don't believe in the super strange i
don't believe in this i don't believe in
that
i believe in social distancing i believe
in respecting one another
and i believe that this will go away
in time and in time we'll be back
and then time will be bad [__]
but you know what guess what
we're already bad [__] we just
got to weather this [__] storm
out
so i want to thank you guys very much
from the bottom of my heart
for backing me for having me at every
situation
i'm happy you like the [__] mind of
joey diaz shirts
i'm happy liking what we're doing with
the joint
you know it's not the church it's a
joint it's something completely
different
it's my heart to yours i love what we're
doing with the patreon
and that's it you bad [__]
we're getting high
we're going to be around for new year's
keep your eyes open on patreon
i might be doing a little something on
new year's on patreon
just to check in with you [__]
wish you
and a happy new year something we'll do
something
so uh keep your eyes open on patreon
youtube uh [__]
twitter i love all you [__] too
facebook but i can't do nothing with you
guys i don't know i don't
i don't even what do you want me to do
send you a post on [__] twitter
but patreon uh i might do a little live
stream
knucklehead joint [__] countdown or
something
and that's it and that's that i want to
thank you
for supporting uncle joey's joint i want
to thank you for finishing out the
church with us this year
and i want to thank you for being you
and for always having my [__]
back
no matter what happens you know i got
you
you got me and they want to be with us
we're together here we're connected
whatever the [__] you want to do you
know what i'm saying so
thank you again and uh have a great new
year's
be safe you got to be home by 10
but you could stay up till 6. don't
forget blue chew
on it get your dick sucked it's gonna be
a beautiful week
i'll see you guys monday january 4th
have a great weekend stay safe all right
you [__]
thank you very much for listening today
you know uncle joey's got your back
uh that's it it's a [__] new year
this is the last
podcast of the year uh
you know we went to the church what a
[__] year
but anyway uncle joey's joint is brought
to you by
blue chew listen you're getting older
your dick ain't working like you used to
oil you're 21
and you're throwing heat with that
[__] popsicle stick
either way blue chew can help you why
because it's the first chewable dick
pill same fda approved activist
ingredients is viagra and cialis
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed [__] positions
so you don't have to go to the doctor's
office and wait online like a [__]
dunce
and people looking at you and you're
making eye contact with some guy
with a [__] [__] up leg you don't
need that and it shifts right to your
[__] door
in a discreet package nobody knows
nothing
not even the [__] mailman unless
she's a female then you want to know
maybe she'll come in and
check out the blue chew witch anyway
that's a fellow defense [__] a male
woman
anyway blue chew is cheaper than a
pharmacy
and you could take them any time day and
night
even on a full stomach if you notice i
don't have none on the table
i had to give mama a stabbing last week
for jingle bells
and you know me i got i got five guns i
got five
bullets in my gun i needed one more
[__] bullet
you want to do the thing so you double
up with blue chew listen this is
for whether you need it or not some
people really [__] need it
and blue chew is tremendous all right
because there's nothing
like slinging dick and giving out
[__] condoms
especially with blue chew nobody likes
limp dick nobody likes coke dick
nobody likes your dick to be soft you
want that [__] to look like one
of dun young humes
missiles over there in korea in fact
that's what they should call your dick
the korean [__] missile crisis
because that's it what else do you want
to call it we've gone off on attention
here but it doesn't matter
what matters is blue chew is here
and it's available to you and if you're
walking around
with erectile dysfunction or whatever
you shouldn't
this is the same fda approved as viagra
see alice
why the [__] are you [__] around with
that [__]
that that guy that's a [__] loser at
the baldega tells you
you don't know nothing he's got nine
kids he hasn't paid child support in 15
[__] years
he's hiding the bodega and you're taking
advice from him
take it from your uncle joey go to
bluechew.com right now
preston joey and what they're going to
do is they're going to send out a free
shipment all you're going to do is pay
for shipping
all right you're gonna get a free
[__] package
all you're gonna do is pay for shipping
when it comes to your door
your ball sack is immediately gonna turn
blue
just from [__] touching the package
why because blue chew
has magic powers kung suckers that's why
your dick will be as hard you could you
could nail [__] nails into the wall
with your dick that if your dick ain't
doing that you need bluetooth
go to bluetooth.com right now pressing
joey
and let's get the [__] party started
i want to thank blue chew and wish them
a happy new year
for [__] showing [__]
youngsters
how to swing some big dick if these
[__] ain't walking crooked
you ain't doing your job all right
bluechew.com
joey i also want to thank honey on it
has been with me for years i love to
death
and why because they [__] put their
[__] money where their mouth is
that's why
the other way around i don't know anyway
honor is the [__]
alpha brain flagship of the organization
why because if you
take it and you don't like it they'll
send you the money back and they'll let
you keep the product who else does that
what do you think
they're going to take the [__]
product back and send it out to some
poor bastard like chinese restaurants do
you ever send food back at a chinese
restaurant break it in half
always i don't care if it's a rib low
mane
break it in half because if not some
porsche muck comes in
and he's eating your low main with your
[__] germs on it
on it don't do that [__] they tell you
keep the product shove it up your ass
if you don't like it it don't work for
you but if you like it you're going to
be back
and if not go with the new mood you got
the alpha brain
powder which just dissolves in water you
got the [__] shroom tech immune and
shroom tech sport
listen you can't lose it on it go to
honor.com right now
i can't give you nothing with
kettlebells and the weights and stuff
but i give you 10 with all the
supplements
the coconut almond protein shoes
are [__] delicious go to honor.com
right now
preston church and let's get this party
started get 10
off sent to your house and start the
year off
right because this is it it's a new year
with a whole new [__] set of rules
even though they want to give you
vaccines and whatever that's got nothing
to do with me
i love you [__] see you monday
the fourth of january tip top magoo
days from my surgery ready to sling dick
have a good weekend [__] happy
new year
[Music]
hmm
so
you